okay so the how works now we got to
figure out the wind and the we're almost
everyone in this room has had an
encounter with a beast one of the six
Infinity stones or substitute the word
encounter for damn near been killed by
one of the six Infinity stones I haven't
but I don't even know what the hell
you're all talking about what happened
to the tesseract after that it's bottom
of the ocean fell out of the plane after
I had to crash it yeah
I've been meaning to ask why did you
have to crash the plane anyway this
bombs on board and you couldn't have
jumped out of the plane before you
crashed it the only thing that once you
come see I'm not the only thing that is
permanent in life is impermanence eggs
breakfast no I'd like a Bloody Mary will
said he stole the Power Stone for more
egg without person more eggs a planet
will was a person a planet like an outer
space look it's like a little puppy all
happy and everything do you want to go
to space you want to go to space puppy
I'll take you to space how long did you
fight these guys - two or three hours
hours did you tari the suckiest Army in
the galaxy why don't you just blow up
the mothership we didn't know that
wasn't
all right we have a plan sixth owns
three teams one shot hi everyone its
charlie we have a whole bunch more
Avengers endgame deleted scenes to
breakdown we also just learned about a
really cool deleted scene of Thanos vs.
The Living Tribunal so we'll break it
all down because they just released
Avengers end game on blu-ray we're doing
that giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
best Marvel phase 4 Marvel phase 5
theory on the video so he just loved war
machines savage Deadpool style takedown
of the ending of Captain America First
Avenger he really brought it in this
film he spent most of the rest of his
scenes making fun of the thick version
of Thor if we can do this you know go
back in time why don't we just find baby
Thanos you know and first of all that's
horrible so you had to crash the plane
because of the dangerous bombs on board
but why didn't you just jump out of the
plane before it hit the ice zero
reaction on Captain America's face but
you can just hear the wheels turning in
his head like wait a minute why didn't I
jump out of the plane
oh yeah cuz the plot needed me to be in
the ice for all those years there's
still a lot of questions about that
alternate Captain America timeline
because he goes back to live with Peggy
but in that timeline there's still a
version of Captain America in the ice so
he basically has to live out that life
with Peggy Carter on the DL so that
nobody finds out that there's two
versions of Captain America running
around even though they wind up deleting
this scene in the final version of the
film I think it still works to inform
his choice to stay in the past with
Peggy Carter when he goes to return the
Infinity stones where they stole them
from and he returned y'all near if that
wasn't clear ever since they explained
the plot of Thor for love and thunder
people like what happened that other
version of Mjolnir do they still have it
no Captain America took that back to the
events of Thor the dark world so that
that version of Thor would have Mjolnir
when he went to fight the dark elves at
the end of that movie because when they
went to steal the Infinity stone it was
sort of in the middle of the movie right
before Frigga winds up dying
just imagine Captain America before he
hops on the platform here at the end of
the movie to go back coming to the
natural conclusion that yeah was kind of
stupid that I went down with a
and in doing so denied myself the
happiness with the love of my life we'll
have to just assume that he did not tell
Peggy Carter about his relationship with
Sharon Carter like you know we're
starting over sort of rebooting my
timeline living out this life with Peggy
Carter let's just pretend like some of
those other things didn't really happen
the scene of Iron Man getting revenge on
rocket is awesome but I get why they
deleted it they wanted to get through
all these battle planning scenes quicker
it was already a pretty long sequence
and even though rocket is being a total
dick to everyone
Ironman shaving his head would have
created some continuity problems for the
rest of the film because it would have
taken rocket a couple weeks to grow some
of that fur back so if they left the
scene in you would have seen rocket
through all of his trip to Asgard with
Thor and all that huge final battle
scene The Avengers Assemble scene with a
weirdly shaved head and it would have
completely ruined a couple big moments
that were meant to be serious because
we'd all be laughing our asses off at
him the whole time
you notice the continuity in this scene
too like a look over a Thor he's mixing
a couple of different Bloody Marys
right after Iron Man's like you want
some eggs buddy you want some breakfast
no I would like a Bloody Mary the other
funny thing about rocket and war
machines sassing everyone the entire
movie is that the two of them wound up
teaming together for the last third of
the movie during the big battle teams
asked for the win you can even see
rocket here riding on war machine during
the huge Avengers Assemble moment like
he's riding a horse and standing on his
shoulder here like he did with Groot in
the first guardians of the galaxy film
in the funny Winter Soldier scene during
the battle of Wakanda an infinity war
and we have to talk about that epic
Thanos Living Tribunal scene that the
writers just told us about what was
meant to happen is that originally at
the end of Infinity Ward there would
have been a scene after Thanos snaps the
Infinity Gauntlet for the first time
before he goes into the soul world of
the soul stone he's taken to the super
flow of the multiverse the super flow is
the space between dimensions in the
multiverse where only the higher cosmic
beings like the Celestials the Living
Tribunal the beyonders in abstract
entities like master order and Lord
chaos can exist he's brought there by
the Living Tribunal to be judged for
crimes against the universe normally
higher beings like this only get
involved when something is powerful as
the Infinity Gauntlet is being used by
someone to alter the universe on a
really massive scale
your big comic book fan you are correct
in suspecting that it was meant to be
the movie version of the Infinity
Gauntlet comic book moment where Thanos
is challenged by the astral
conflagration a team of the most
powerful celestial beings in astral
God's in the universe
the writers explained that Thanos is
sentenced they were handing down was
just that he would be permanently
damaged in a week for the rest of his
life and he would die if he ever tried
to use the Infinity Gauntlet again like
this the funny thing is though is that
in the comics Stannis was able to defeat
all these astral gods it was meant to be
this oh crap moment like now finally
they're stepping in and Thanos is gonna
get his ass handed to him because these
are all the most powerful characters in
the comics that we've ever seen teaming
up together against one single person
but because the power of the Infinity
Gauntlet he's able to soak all their
damage then eternity steps in to stop
him an even higher level being the
living embodiment of the multiverse and
everyone's like oh [ __ ] now he's finally
gonna get it but big surprise Thanos is
still able to soak all of eternities
damage and winds up throwing him in
Chains it was a big rug pool moment just
meant to show you how powerful fan oohs
had become with the Infinity Gauntlet no
living being God or man could kill him
while he still wore the gauntlet so you
can see why they didn't want to take the
movie that far it would have gotten way
too weird for casual audiences and they
would have had added this big complete
explainer on the concept of the Living
Tribunal and eternity at the end of an
already very long movie but if you're
really upset about them cutting stuff
like that because they're doing Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness in
the Eternals movie is all about the
history of the Celestials we'll get into
more of this grand cosmic Jack Kirby
level weirdness in Marvel phase 4 and
Marvel phase 5 once you start doing
characters like that it makes it a lot
easier to explain characters like
Galactus and I am really excited for a
Marvel phase 5 Galactus cameo he's big
enough to be one of the next fan OHS
Infinity Gauntlet level arcs for the MCU
in the next six or seven years given
that Marvel phase four is only two years
I don't think it's gonna take another 10
years to get to something that big
phases are happening much quicker now
and I saw a lot of you on my shang-chi
video yesterday asking about the
Mandarin possibly turning into a bigger
MCU villain because the 10 alien rings
the power that he wears are so powerful
but I feel like they could take that
move
either way either the rings will be a
really big deal and he'll turn into an
Avengers villain somebody that no one
person could actually defeat by
themselves or they'll downplay it in
shame she will defeat the Mandarin
during the Shang Chi movie and you'll
never hear about him again
Marvel has been known to pull the rug
out from under us every once in a while
with a really big comic book thing
something that's super huge in the
comics but that points up being sort of
a throwaway joke during the movies you
got a minute to live fill up with words
just a role the Mandarin but post all
your theories about Galactus in the
other major cosmic characters in the MCU
movies going forward because of the
Avengers endgame blue raid they dropped
a whole bunch more deleted scenes and
bonus features I'll try to do videos
about that stuff through the rest of the
week I'm also still working on a Thor
for love and thunder video that should
post pretty soon congratulations to the
giveaway winner from my last big video
Daniel Kim please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details click here for the shank cheap
plot teaser an Iron Man Easter eggs
video and click here for that Deadpool 3
teaser video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
you